Thanks for the invitation.
Um I'm really
I'm really happy to be part of this
school.
Um in this presentation I will be uh
talking about a recent work we have and
this is a joint work with uh James
Rowbottom, Ben Chamberlain, Thomas
Markovich, and Michael Bronstein.
Um entitled Graph Neural Network as
Gradient Flows.
Um
The structure of the presentation is
actually going to be as follows. So,
we
are going to talk a lot about graph
preliminaries,
uh spectral analysis and diffusion
energy on graphs, and dynamical systems
on graphs. So,
half of the presentation roughly is
going to um
be about
uh classical tools on on sing to analyze
signals on graphs
and dynamical systems on graphs.
This is independent of message passing
neural networks, but this will be
hopefully useful to provide a sort of
context and some perhaps like lens
that you can that you can have through
which like look at the MPNN with uh some
fresh eyes and then
dig a little bit deeper into our paper.
Um I uh trust that by now you've you've
seen
um
generally what graph neural networks
are.
I'm going to recall that at some point,
but I will be mostly focusing as I said
on these
uh analytical tools uh and in some
regard also classical tools.
Um so, let me start by setting mostly a
few notations. So, we will consider
always a graph
uh consisting of a vertex set V and edge
set E,
and I will always assume this graph to
be undirected.
Um we have from now on whenever you're
going to see the uh
a notation N, this will be the number of
nodes of the graph.
Uh and we have the most important
matrices that are
denoted by A and D respectively, which
are the adjacency matrices that
uh represent the connectivity in a graph
and the degree matrix, which is a
diagonal matrix
that um
we get by basically row summing A. And
so,
just to set the dimensions, both A and D
are going to be square
um matrices of dimension n by n.
Uh an important operator that we can
construct out of A and D is the
normalized adjacency that we denote by
A-bar.
And for people that have already seen
graph convolution networks, i.e., GCNs,
this is the
uh matrix adopted in their paper and in
in in that uh architecture. And there
are a few reasons for why
one would like to have A-bar rather than
A.
Uh I'm not going to spend time on this,
but I want to say that this is a a
fairly classical construction. And in
fact,
the arguably most important operator
that one can associate with a graph is
the Laplacian
that I define as identity minus A-bar.
Um now,
a few things. So, first of all, I can
think of that, that remember is a square
n by n matrix,
as an operator that acts on signals. So,
a signal is a map that associates, say,
to each node
uh a scalar number. And therefore, I can
represent this this signal as an
n-dimensional vector, as I'm going to um
show in the next slide.
Um
and therefore, I can think of the action
of the Laplacian matrix on a signal,
which is an n-dimensional vector, as an
operator acting on the signal. And I
have in this equation here in this box
the
expression of this operator.
And for people that like have some
familiarity with the standard Laplacian
in you know Euclidean space, you can see
why this matrix here delta is in fact
called the Laplacian because there is an
averaging type of property that is sort
of similar to the second order operator
in Euclidean space.
Now, this Laplacian operator is
symmetric and is also positive
semi-definite. So, we can have we can
you know look at these at its
eigenvalues and we can order them from
the lowest to highest.
Now,
two important properties. First of all,
the lowest eigenvalue is always zero and
in fact the multiplicity of this
eigenvalue will give you the number of
connected components in the graph.
And second, the highest eigenvalue,
which is also the spectral radius of the
matrix, and I'm using the notation rho
delta, it's always a number smaller or
equal than two.
Now, usually people refer to these
eigenvalues as
frequencies
and I can also use the uh
um I have a notation also for the
eigenvectors of the Laplacian, which are
these phi delta,
which are n-dimensional vectors.
Now, a maybe a a a an important
observation is that there are other
versions of Laplacians that one can use.
Um um everything I'll I'll be saying
will
extend to the unnormalized Laplacian,
too.
Um
but it will not extend to
non-symmetric Laplacians like the random
walk ones. And I I promise you that by
the end of this talk you you you'll
understand why.
Now,
how can we use the Laplacian? So, one
one important quantity on a graph is a
Dirichlet energy. So, as I said,
consider a signal or feature on a graph,
and we can think for example the
temperature
at each node of the graph. So, we have a
temperature for each node of the graph,
and we can think of now of this uh
temperature for each node as a vector
where I stack basically each each entry
and get an n-dimensional vector. So,
once now I have a signal as an
n-dimensional vector, I can of course
decompose this signal into the basis of
eigenvectors of the Laplacian.
Um
I see there is
there is no condition denominator
Laplace equations. Um
Technically, the you you would have
you would have some
connect connectedness type of
assumption. So, something I I didn't
want to like uh stress too much like uh
make that this like to dance, but of
course
ideally one would like to avoid to
consider isolated nodes
um that would have basically degree
zero.
Or you could have isolated nodes with
self-loops, at least they have positive
degree. So,
um we can think of a graph where we
ignore isolated nodes, so that the
denominator is always well defined.
Um
So,
now what I was saying is if we have this
decomposition into the eigenvector
basis, then
um
we can use the Laplacian to so uh sort
of measure the smoothness of the signal.
Now,
the Dirichlet energy, and a few of you
might may uh already know the uh
analogous quantity for Euclidean space,
can be also defined on graphs, and we
have this definition where basically we
sum over all edges
the deviation of this of the signal
value that not I and the signal value to
not J for all edges that connect I and J
up to this normalization by degree, once
again, let's let's remove isolated
nodes.
And I can rewrite this
uh quantity in compact form as an inner
product between the signal and the
Laplacian, right?
Um and in fact, I can use the eigen
decomposition I had upstairs to
write the Dirichlet energy in terms of
the coefficients
of the signal with respect to the eigen
vector basis of the Laplacian.
So, what I want to emphasize here is
that the Dirichlet energy measures the
smoothness of the signal because the
lower the Dirichlet energy,
the lower these
deviations along edges, and therefore
the smoother the signal. And vice versa,
if the if the Dirichlet energy is
higher, then the signal is going to be
less smooth.
Um and in fact,
people refer to this quantity inside the
L2 norm as the gradient of the of the
feature
along an edge.
Um but what is important is that
equivalently, because of these
equalities, I can measure the smoothness
of the signal in terms of
the mass
that the signal has projected on the
lowest frequency eigen vector. So,
the larger the CL for low L, then the
the smoother the signal because we have
lower Dirichlet energy.
Um
Oh.
Okay, so I have two questions.
Um
maybe I I have a question for the um
organizers or the like I can try to uh
deal with them a little bit better. How
much time do I have?
Yeah, so you have 1 hour.
1 hour. Okay.
Um fine. Yeah, so
why do we care about the smoothness of
the signal? So, in general,
you can think let's say for for example,
you think of images, but and you can
think of images as a subclass of graphs,
right? Then
you want to have some operations on
images, and these operations uh
for example, can be blurring or can be
sharpening. So, these type of operations
are
blurring that
would be like uh you kind of diffuse the
image, and this is like it increasing
the smoothness of the image, or you can
do sharpening like enhancement, which
means for example, you you do some edge
detection, and you may in fact uh
decrease the smoothness of the signal.
So,
assessing how smooth a signal is, like
for example, colors on an image or an
image itself, is one way of monitoring
what kind of transformations you can do
on that on that images.
Um
And you but you're going to see in a
second why also like we care about that
in the context of graphs and graph
neural networks.
Um
I'm not sure what I should repeat
specifically. If there's a point I
should I have to repeat, I can I can do
that.
Uh if you had a loose signal
Um
So, the role of self-loops is actually
an entire a topic that is not entirely
understood.
I I guess the heuristics is at least at
least in the context of GNNs is that
if you add a self-loop, nodes will tend
to retain most information about
themselves,
and this will alleviate like mixing too
much with the information of their
neighbors. So, in fact, it might change
uh information on the graph, but in a
positive way. And especially if we have
a heterophily uh rather than a
homophily, but this is terminology that
I will introduce later in in the chat in
the talk, so I don't want to sort of
like um confuse you too much at this
point.
Um right. So, this energy is a function
that uh monitors smoothness in the
graph.
Uh but I also want to give you a rough
picture that um perhaps also partly
answers the questions about why do we
care about smoothness, what is telling
us about that. So, consider like a a
process that changes on time in the
graph. Like for example, you can think
of temperature on a graph that evolves
in time due to some, I don't know,
external factor like heat
uh up um that is applied to the graph.
Now, for each time, we can always take
the temperature as an n-dimensional
vector and write this temperature in
terms of the eigen vector basis. So, now
the coefficients that with respect to
this eigen vector basis will of course
be functions of functions of time.
Now, a rough description is the
following. If the high frequency
components, so we by that I mean the
coefficients cl
with l large, so the coefficients that
multiply the eigen vectors of the
Laplacian with larger eigen values, they
decrease with time,
so I keep the low frequency components,
but I throw away the high frequency
component, then I'm effectively
effectively doing some blurring
denoising type of operations, which is
what for example also has been studied
for images. So, this will increase the
smoothness of the signal, right? So,
this is a type of operation that will
denoise the graph and can be useful in
many in many situations.
But on the other side, if I throw away
the low frequency components and I keep
the high frequency component, then I say
that I have a high pass filtering,
meaning that I do the other op the
opposite transformation, I sharpen the
signal, and I and I sort of like enhance
the signal. Now,
this image is essentially describing
what I just said, because you have the
same graph,
and what you have is the four the first
four eigen vectors of the Laplacian.
Now,
you can see how if you move from left to
right, the eigen vector become
becomes less and less smooth. So, in the
first case,
the eigen vector takes the same value at
each node. So, you can think of
temperature being the same everywhere.
But then as you move from left to right,
the signal becomes less and less smooth
because now you have temperature that
changes in in let's say multiple places
as you as you go from left to right. So,
left is low frequency, everything is
smooth, everything changes very little,
and then as you increase the frequency,
uh you you decrease the smoothness and
you can have signals that are also more
complicated. Okay?
Now,
a very very standard example of an
operation that is a low pass filtering,
so an operation that makes the signal
super smooth, is the heat equation. So,
remember that I can have an input
signal, say,
temperature,
and then
the Dirichlet energy can be written in
compact form as this inner product.
So, let's say I want to minimize the
Dirichlet energy. In other words, let's
say I want to make my my signal, my
feature, smoother. I want to do some
blurring or some denoising, right?
What I can do is take infinitesimal
steps in the direction of steepest
descent of the energy, and therefore
basically obtain a dynamical system or
differential equation where
my
feature evolves in time in the direction
of of minus the gradient of the energy.
But you can see from this equation here
that if I take the gradient of that, I
will just get minus the
the Laplacian times the solution. So,
this is the classical heat equation
where we
evolve the some some feature by minus
the Laplacian of the graph. And in fact,
by design, because we are evolving in
the direction of of steepest descent of
the energy, the energy will decrease in
time, and in fact, if I let the heat
equation run for infinite time,
in the limit, I'm converging to
something that
is in the kernel of the Laplacian, as in
satisfies Laplacian times the limit
equals zero.
So,
the take-home message here is, if I have
a low-pass dynamics, so a dynamics that
is smoothing something that is denoising
a a signal,
if I let it run for too long, the
feature become indistinguishable,
because everything is becoming
increasingly similar to each other up to
a point where I can't distinguish
anything no more, as in the picture I
was showing you before, where the
temperature was the same at each node.
Um now, we've
Right now, we've talked about scalar
signals, but of course, most of the
times, especially for GNNs, as as we'll
see later, we have vector signals. So,
for each node now, we have a
D-dimensional vector, so we can
represent the feature as a matrix that's
of dimension N by D,
and we can generalize the Dirichlet
energy in this case fairly easily. So,
we again sum over all edges, but now,
instead of having the scalar deviation,
we have the L2 norm of the vectors.
And not surprisingly, as as I've shown
you before, if you take the the gradient
flow of that, so if you evolve the
signal in the direction of minus the
gradient of the Dirichlet energy, you're
going to see the heat equation, but down
on each coordinate, or aka in each
feature channel. So, for each
R that goes from 1 to D.
Um
this is a slide that may sound a bit
technical, but in fact, it is the key
approach that that we've used in our in
our paper to analyze mathematically
everything in an easy form. So,
the upshot is if I'm given a feature
matrix, I can always vectorize this
matrix by stacking all the columns into
a longer column, right?
Uh now, if I do that, so I move from n
by d to nd,
then I can rewrite the Dirichlet energy
in a compact form,
and you can see now that the heat
equation I was showing you above can be
nicely written as a vector equation,
where I have a vector on the left-hand
side, then I have this operator, which
is basically I'm I'm broadcasting the
Laplacian on each entry, and then I have
another vector here. So, I don't want to
you to get too stressed about the
details here, but and I invite you for
example to maybe check out our paper for
for the details, but the
take-home message here is that this
tensor product or Kronecker product
formalism
allows us to uh reduce matrix
differential equations to vector
differential equations, and vector
differential equations are much easier
to deal with.
And I'm going to show you now a
motivating example um that hopefully
will uh also clear things out a little
bit about uh this this stuff with with
this graph in. So,
let's suppose we have a dynamical
process on a graph, and we want to say
is this dynamical process
a smoothing process or a sharpening
process? So,
are the low frequencies dominating or
are the high frequencies dominating? How
can we determine that?
The the
the key point is we want we can use the
Dirichlet energy, but we have to
normalize the solution first. And this
motivating example would be to justify
that.
So,
let's consider a very simple
differential equation. We have a feature
me solution feature matrix that is
evolved as normalized adjacency times
the solution and I can always factorize
that as I as I showed you in the
previous slide. Now, recall that the
normalized adjacency is is just identity
minus the Laplacian. Now, this is all
that's symmetric matrix. So, linear
dynamical equations, I can exponentiate
and get my solution. So, for each for
each feature channel, I just have to
look at the exponential of this matrix
times my initial condition.
Now,
exponentiating a matrix means
essentially that I have to decompose the
matrix using eigenvectors and
eigenvalues. So,
I can rewrite my solution as
a combination
of the eigenvectors of the Laplacian.
Then, I have my the projection of my
initial condition into the eigenvector.
And then, I have an exponential here
that is basically determining how fast
or I am growing or how fast I am
decaying in time along that eigenvector,
right?
Now, you recall that the smoothest
eigenvector
is the one that is satisfied equation
delta phi zero equals zero. Now,
if I'm looking at the projection along
this eigenvector of my solution at time
t,
then I get this equation. So,
my the projection along the
smoothest eigenvector is actually
growing exponentially fast. And this is
the component that is growing the
fastest in my equation. Now,
if I have an equation and my the
projection along the smoothest
eigenvector is growing the fastest, I'd
like to say this is a smoothing process
because what is basically driving my
equation is the vector that is the
smoothest one. So, I I'm I I've told you
that the Dirichlet energy measures the
smoothness. So, is it true then that the
Dirichlet energy is going to zero
as we progress in time?
This is not the case. So, the Dirichlet
energy is still
basically in almost any case will
diverge to infinity. So, what is
happening here? I I think I have a
process that is smoothing, but the
Dirichlet energy seem to go to infinity.
Well, the point here is that we are not
normalizing the solution. So,
if we normalize the solution, so we
divide the solution by its norm, then
actually we find that the Dirichlet
energy of this is going to zero.
And in fact, for each channel, for each
feature channel, the normalized solution
is converging to something that is in
the kernel of the Laplacian, so satisfy
this equation.
So, the upshot of this motivating
example is the Dirichlet energy is not
enough because it it does not account
for the scale of a signal. We have to
normalize the solution first. And once
we normalize, now this quantity here is
a good measurement of whether my process
is becoming smoother and smoother or
whether it's becoming
like more sharp, like less smooth.
Um these are definitions uh we've
introduced in our paper to basically
capture that. So,
we say that a dynamical system
initialized at some,
you know, in input feature,
is low-frequency dominant, and I'm I
will be using this acronym LFT,
if the Dirichlet energy of the
normalized solution is going to zero for
as we progress in time.
And the reason why that makes sense is
that one can actually show
that
if this is satisfied, then basically
up to subsequences, and I invite you to
read the appendices for why this
condition in fact is necessary,
um
you will converge to a solution that is
in the kernel of the Laplacian. So, this
lemma is essentially telling you, yes,
this definition makes sense. The
Dirichlet energy of the normalized
solution is in fact telling me
whether
what is the fastest component, what is
the component that is driving my
equation. And if this is going to zero,
then
such component would be the smoothest
possible one.
And we can have exactly the same
definition, but for the case, which is
the high frequency dominant. So, the
Dirichlet energy satisfy this bound.
That means that the Dirichlet energy of
a normalized signal is always bounded by
the spectral radius over two. The over
two is a convention we've used in our
paper.
So,
the very same motivation allows us to
have the following definition. We say
that a dynamical system on a graph is
high frequency dominant or HFT if the
Dirichlet energy of the normalized
solution approaches its
maximum as we progress in time. And
again, this makes sense because we can
show that if this is satisfied, then
the normalized solution is converging to
a signal
that will be the largest frequency
eigenvector. So, the least smooth
eigenvector of the Laplacian.
So,
I've given a lot of information, but the
take a message is now we have two
definitions LFD and HFD.
LFD
dynamics means
at the end of the day, I have a
smoothing dynamics, something that will
make things increasingly similar.
HFD is the opposite dynamics, is a
sharpening dynamics where I am enhancing
rather than denoising.
But why would we need such definitions
in the context of GNNs. So, we finally
uh
can talk about MPNNs after all these
ex courses. So,
we have a graph, we have some input
features,
we have potentially an encoding map, and
then we have update functions for each
layer that process these features. And
generally, message passing neural
networks can be written like this. So,
we have that the representation
at each node at layer t + 1 is given as
a function of the representation of the
previous layer and the representations
of each of each
of each neighbor, right? So,
message passing means I'm using the
given graph as the actual computational
graph to propagate information.
Now, message passing networks are
you know, quite successful in fact,
quite simple, but we have to talk about
problems. Otherwise, we
our research will be over. So,
we have problems, luckily enough, and
the main ones are expressivity. We're
not going to talk about expressivity in
the classical sense of comparison with
WL test today.
The second problem is what I refer as
low versus high pass. So,
how do message passing networks perform
if we need more than a smoothing
process, if we need more than denoising?
And this is related to this now
classical problem of over smoothing,
which happens if we stack many, many
layers, and at the end, we see that the
representation of each node are becoming
indistinguishable.
And another problem is over squashing.
This is
also something I I I worked on, and it
basically is like
it it's a problem of information flow
that can struggle due to the graph
topology. This is independent of the
specific choice of MPNN, but will be
affected by the graph topology. Now, in
the rest of this presentation, I will be
focusing on the second point, but of
course, these are very much related. If
we have an MPNN that can perform
uh not just as a low pass, but also as
for example as a high pass, then of
course it's more expressive. And
just to set some terminology, uh we
usually think of a semi-supervised
setting where we have a a subset of the
nodes that are that are labeled
and we want to predict labels on a test
set.
Now, there are two notions that usually
people now refer to in this in this
scenario. The first one is homophily.
Homophily means neighbors
often share the same label. So, labels
are smooth and therefore a low pass is
good here because uh most of the times
we just want some denoising because
everything I'm connected to is actually
similar to me.
The opposite case is heterophily. So,
labels are not smooth and therefore we
expect low pass to be actually bad and
this is this finally circles back to the
question of why do we care about
smoothness that as someone asked at the
beginning. So,
we care about smoothness because if a
process is
increasing the smoothness of the signal,
then such process could be uh beneficial
if we have homophily,
but it could be actually harmful uh
uh
damaging if we have heterophily because
we are making things similar when they
shouldn't.
So, and the dual perspective of course,
this extends also to task like graph
classification and graph regression
because one can think of homophily and
heterophily as short-range relations. I
only care about what's connected to me
versus versus long-range relations. I
actually care about things that are also
not connected to me.
Um the standard example of MPNNs are
GCNs, so graph convolutional networks,
where a layer is basically given by a
some non-linear activation function,
then we have a message passing matrix
that encodes graph information, in this
case the normalized adjacency. We have
the solution, and then we have this
right-hand side multiplication, which is
referred to as channel mixing, because
of course it will act on the on the
entries of each feature and and
potentially mix the entries.
Now, GCNs, you know, are successful, are
extremely simple, but there have been
scenarios where they seem to struggle.
So, the first one is heterophilic
graphs,
and the second one is a degradation when
increasing the depth. So, this is the
problem of over-smoothing, and
there's been quite some analysis in the
literature about this problem that can
be sort of
condensed in the following statement.
So, what has been shown is that the
Dirichlet energy of a solution of a GCN
is going to zero
if the singular values of the channel
mixing are sufficiently small. And this
sufficiently small is depending
basically on properties like the
spectral gap of the graph.
So,
this is not okay, because we know that
if Dirichlet energy is going to zero,
then we have a smoothing process, which
of course may not be uh good, and we may
lose information.
But this statement is also
tackling a specific angle of the
problem.
We have this assumption on the channel
mixing, which is sufficiently small in
terms of singular value. So,
is it the case that we can generalize
such a result when we don't have this
assumption?
Is it the case that sort of graph
convolutional networks are in fact
doomed, as in they can only act as
low-pass, or maybe we can say something
a little bit different.
So,
to kind of tackle some of these
questions, we have
uh
tried to follow a sort of same
multi-particle approach to GNNs, where
we think of node features as particles
in in RT.
And we have this gradient flow
framework, which we termed graph, where
the message passing neural networks can
be interpreted as some multi-particle
dynamics that minimize a learnable
energy.
Now, uh on the right, just to give you a
an idea,
this is a small graph, and this is the
actual gradient flow framework that is
able to um sort of induce attraction on
one of the sort of axis and repulsion on
the other. And this is These are both
useful to to you know, bring things that
should be brought together closer, but
also separate things that are different.
Now, what does What What is the outline
of our contribution? So,
as I said, we don't parameterize the
message passing neural network's
equations, but we do parameterize an
energy that models these interactions
between particles, and then the message
passing neural network will follow the
direction of steepest descent of a
learnable energy.
Now, we show that the channel mixing W,
in fact, can learn to induce either a
low-frequency dominant or a
high-frequency dominant dynamics
thanks to its spectrum. So, the channel
mixing, in fact, is powerful enough
to
adaptively learn to to do more smoothing
or more enhancing thanks to its positive
and negative eigenvalues.
Um and in fact,
if you think about the the
picture I showed you before, you can you
you in this framework, you can think of
positive and negative eigenvalues of W
as generating attraction attraction and
repulsion. So, you can think of forces
in in particle space.
Um I'm going to address that question in
a second. Uh at least I'm going to open
the chat now.
Um and then these
sort of like
dynamics can induce a framework that can
learn to be LFD or HFD, so it can adapt
to homophilic and heterophilic graphs
because in the first case we expect, as
I said, low frequency dominant to be
good. In the second case we expect high
frequency dominant to be good.
Um
Oh yeah, I mean uh this is not the
presentation is going to be uh it's not
going to be over here. Now we're going
to
uh you know, dig into and explain um
uh more the role of the channel mixing,
right?
At least in this gradient flow
framework.
Um okay, so
uh
Right, I think yes.
Okay, so just a recap, uh we're going to
um
look at um Jinan's dynamical equation.
So remember like
we can think of residual network ResNet
as a discretization of differential
equations when the step size
uh goes to zero. And this is of course
can be done in the case of residual
message passing neural networks, too,
where we have a residual block. We have
a step size and then if the step size
goes to zero, then this is just a
discretization of differential
equations.
And
there've been instances of continuous
message passing neural networks. Um I
think I need uh I have to like uh you
know, speed up a bit to to go through
the end. So I'm I'm just going to be
saying here that in all of these models
you actually parameterize the equation.
So a kind of question would be how do we
choose such equations, right?
Now
since we're looking at the framework of
differential equations and dynamical
systems, there is a a very very special
class of differential equations that are
gradient flows. Now, gradient flows are
equations where
the ODE is actually the
steepest descent of an energy. So,
you are evolving some equation some
function in the direction of minus the
gradient of an energy.
Now, these equations are very special.
They are used everywhere in in you know,
in physics, in geometry, because instead
of basically studying the equations, you
can study the energy and the energy is
already giving you a lot of information
because you know that any solution you
are going to you're going to you're
going to get is minimizing the energy.
So, you know the dynamics of what it's
trying to achieve.
So, that the key question that is sort
of motivating our work is, okay, what if
we parameterize an energy, so we learn
an energy rather than the message
passing neural network's equations.
So, we can do that
and
if we do that, then we you can interpret
this process as let's generalize the
classical Dirichlet energy that is not
learnable with something that allows us
to find the right notion of smoothness
for the problem.
And now, we once we parameterize the the
energy, the message passing neural
network equations will just follow as uh
the gradient flow of this energy, which
means as minus the gradient of of this
energy.
Right?
Now, let's try to um
be a little bit more specific about
that. So,
how can we
generalize the Dirichlet energy on a
graph?
So, let's suppose we have a matrix that
represents essentially a metric in
Euclidean space. So,
this is a positive semi-definite matrix,
so we can use the Cholesky decomposition
to write this as W transpose W.
And what we can do is
on the left-hand side here, you had the
classical Dirichlet energy where we sum
over over all edges the gradient of the
feature squared.
And now we can generalize that by
waiting this L2 norm with some learnable
W. So, I'm let literally waiting the the
the L2 norm.
And this would be a reasonable first
step. I don't have time to motivate
this, but in our paper we draw some
comparisons with harmonic map flow that
were used in image processing, too.
Now,
let's say I want to minimize the
Dirichlet energy weighted with W. So,
what do we expect? So, we want to
minimize this quantity, but this
quantity is a sum of squared function,
so each a sum and has to be minimized.
So, we expect the gradient to go to zero
except when is inside the kernel of H.
So, except when basically, for example,
W times the gradient is zero.
And
this is precisely what happens. So, we
can treat W as learnable weights. We can
derive the gradient flow of this energy,
which is a quite simple equation. So,
this resembles GCN because we have a
solution, we have a message passing
matrix that in this case is minus the
Laplacian,
but then on the right-hand side we have
this channel mixing acting on the
features.
And now the proposition, and I'm going
to state this informally, but we have
the specific the
precise statement in the paper, is that
you there is no W we can learn
that will separate the limit embeddings
of nodes that have same degree and same
input features. So, you give me two
nodes,
they have the same degree, they have
same input features. If I run this
equation for too long, their
representation will become the same. I
cannot distinguish these nodes anymore.
And in fact, if W has a zero kernel, so
the kernel of W is just a zero vector,
then nodes with the same degree will
converge to the same representation.
This is irrespective of the their input
features. So, this is a
a bad thing. And in fact, in the context
of GNNs, this is what people
traditionally refer to as
over-smoothing, where nodes that have
same degree will converge to the same
representation, forgetting all the other
information, features, and anything of
that sort.
And this is in particular, so this is a
little bit more technical, but
over-smoothing this occurs
independently of the spectral radius of
W.
So, this and this is true even for
equations that are residual, because
this is a differential equation. So,
when we discretize, we're going to get
residual equations. So, um this is
different from what is was known or
studied previously in literature. We
have no type of assumption of the form
we need singular values to be small
enough, and we are looking at equations
that are actually residual. So, the
take-home message here is, if we can
control the sign of the eigenvalues of
the channel mixing, which is what is
acting on the right,
then this is very powerful, and it's
going to generate the dynamics that can
always be uh low-frequency dominant, and
in fact, it will always over-smooth in
the limit. So, this is not great. I
mean,
we said,
"If we have something like that, it's
going to definitely fail if we have a
tropy, right?" So, how can we modify
this a little bit
to make it more general? So,
remember that we have the Dirichlet
energy that is written like this,
with this weighted W. So, what we do is,
okay, let's replace each occurrence of W
transpose W
with symmetric matrices omega and W
that are now independent. And the
symmetry is actually uh necessary here.
If we do that, now the energy is written
as a the
of two terms. The first one, as you can
see here,
has no dependence on the edges, no
dependence on the graph connectivity.
The second one depends on the edge
connectivity, because it it it will sum
again over all edges. And then we have
these inner products that are weighted
by omega and W. So, how can we interpret
this?
Um
of course, we can take the gradient flow
of that, and the gradient flow it
will become again increasingly similar
to graph convolutional models, because
it's a differential equation. But then
we have a term that resembles graph
sage, because we have feature sort of
like mixing of the channels acting on
the solution without any graph
information. And then we have what is
essentially graph convolutional block,
right?
Remember that omega and W here are
symmetric matrices.
But what I care about now is in the
interpretation. So,
not features are particles.
So, the external energy is independent
of the graph topology, as I as I was
saying. So, this can be interpreted as
an external field in in in this particle
space.
The pairwise energy is a potential
energy that does depend on the edges and
can be interpreted as pairwise
interaction of the particles that are
basically governed by W. And remember
that in our framework, W and omega are
what we are going to learn, right?
But W is symmetric, so W can always be
decomposed into positive and negative
eigenvalues. And I'm using this notation
just to mean this positive and negative
eigenvalue decomposition.
Now, if we do that, we can rewrite the
same energy in a more explicit way as a
first term that is just, again,
independent of the graph structure.
But then this these two terms are
actually what very interesting, because
now we have a gradient flow that
minimizes the energy. So, if we want to
minimize the energy, what we get is
attraction.
And this is through the positive
eigenvalues of W because these terms
here, remember the theta plus are
encoding positive eigenvalues of W, is
decreasing edge-wise.
But we also have repulsion because
the negative eigenvalues of W are acting
now on the gradient, and these terms
here are increasing along the evolution.
The reason why they are increasing is
because they appear here with a minus
sign. So, if we take gradient descent,
this uh last term here would increase.
So, what we found is just without
looking at the equation, just looking at
the energy, we know that whatever
message passing a network we're going to
get as gradient flow of this energy,
it will have two type of behaviors,
attraction by the positive eigenvalues
of W, repulsion by the negative
eigenvalues of W. But attraction is
something that makes things smoother
because it it pulls things together.
Repulsion is something that will
enhance. It will pull things apart. So,
we expect attraction to be
inducing LFT dynamics, and repulsion to
be inducing HFT dynamics.
And this is precisely what happens.
So,
I think I have to run a little bit. So,
I'm just going to say that this
proposition, again, I I've reported an
informal statement, is precisely saying
what I've just said. So, if you have
enough negative eigenvalues for W, and
remember W is what you want to learn,
with respect to the positive
eigenvalues, then the graph high
frequencies dominate. So, your dynamics
is HFT. You are not going to oversmooth,
and in fact, you are going to separate
things apart. Remember that picture I
was showing you before when you had this
separation along one axis. So, the
theoretical upshot is the channel mixing
W that enters GCN and stuff like that is
in fact quite powerful, and the
distribution of its eigenvalues, in
particular how much mass I have into the
negative eigenvalues compared to the
positive ones, determine if the dynamics
is LFD or HFD. So, I can adapt um to do
smoothing or enhancing.
Um I'm going to skip this slide. This is
just some comparison we do with uh a few
continuous general models by showing
that they actually
uh are never HFD, so they can never act
by as like high frequency dominated,
which is a limitation.
Um and then I can move to the
the discretization of our framework,
because at the end of the day we want to
discretize our our equations, and of
course we do that by introducing a step
size, and then our linear gradient flow
framework can can be written like this
in in a simplified form,
where the only constraint is essentially
that our channel mixing is a symmetric
matrix, and this is shared across
layers.
Um
I think um yeah, I think I I I want to
like maybe uh skip the details here, but
this is so um I want to say that the
main theorem of our paper is essentially
translating the result from the
continuous case, so time is continuous,
to the discrete case, time uh is
discrete, so we talk about layers. And
this theorem is telling you a few
things, um
which um I think I I can just skip to
here, to the take home messages, because
uh we don't have time. So,
once we discretize this gradient flow,
we find that
first, differently from previous
results, I can induce a high frequency
dominated dynamics thanks to the
negative eigenvalues of W, and there is
no requirement on how big these negative
eigenvalues are, provided that the
positive eigenvalues are small enough.
So, it's the concentration of positive
and negative eigenvalues of W that is
really uh determining how the dynamics
are inside an MPNN is going to behave.
Also,
we we found that if we drop a residual
connection, then your dynamics is going
to be low frequency dominated
independently of the sign and magnitude
of the eigenvalues of W. So, the
eigenvalues of W can help you steering
away to steer away the the process from
being smoothing
provided that you have a residual
connection. Otherwise, they cannot do
that.
Um I'm going to finish this presentation
by giving you some ablation studies that
sort of corroborate and confirm our
theoretical analysis.
Um this slide is just to show you that
basically the
the ingredients of this framework are an
encoding block that acts node-wise.
We have symmetric channel mixing
matrices omega and W that are shared
across layers.
We have a decoding block to for the
classification. And then we have this
simple linear
message passing your network star
residual because they come from a
differential equations. And then we have
this block here where we have
potentially a source term. And And then
we have the gradient flow blocks that I
was describing with symmetric matrices.
Um
Of course, the key thing here is let's
suppose for simplicity that omega is
zero.
How do we choose um
um
how do we enforce symmetry at the level
of W? So,
of course, the simplest case would be
let's learn W prime and then let's
consider W prime plus W prime transpose.
That's That's simple enough, but there
is no control on the spectrum here,
right?
On the other case, we have ways of
controlling
directly the spectrum by taking what we
call prod or neck prod. So, we learn W
prime, but then we take W prime
transpose W prime. And but the problem
of this, of course, is this construction
will always give you eigen values with
the same sign. So, either
or all non-negative or all non-positive.
And finally, we have
what we call diagonally dominant.
Um
I don't think it's crucial here to
discuss the details, but the the um
main factor here is basically
controlling the diagonal terms of W and
the off-diagonal separately, and one can
then rely on Gershgorin theorem to sort
sort of like
uh monitor the spectrum. And in fact, we
have some ablation study in our paper
that show that this configuration seems
to be more efficient with respect to the
hidden dimension. So,
um an important bit is something that I
hope you've already picked up is this
model is or I should say framework is
quite simple. So, it's linear.
There is no attention mechanism. There
is no, you know,
some complicated stuff going on. And in
fact, it's basically faster than GCN
because we are also pre-processing using
nodes rather than edges. So,
and these ablation studies just to
confirm this is like essentially a super
light uh framework.
Um now,
I want to finish this presentation by
saying
the by showing you a few a few charts,
but let me recap what our theory
basically said. So,
positive eigen values of W
induce attraction in a residual
convolution model. This is good if you
have a homophily.
Negative eigen values of W induce
repulsion in a residual convolution
model. This we expect to be good on uh
heterophily.
And then if we drop the residual block,
then
there is no W that can steer away the
diffusion from low frequency dominance.
So,
if we drop the residual block, we expect
the model to suffer
in heterophily, no matter the spectrum
of W.
And to sort of justify these claims, we
use these sort of synthetic data sets
where
we can sort of generate
some
targets of homophily by preferential
attachment.
Um
the ablation study essentially confirmed
that. So, for example, we observe that
if we have
only negative eigenvalues, this is going
to be much better on low homophily, but
it's going to be much worse on higher
homophily because we can only do
repulsion. And the other way around for
prod, so if we have only positive
eigenvalues.
Um
this is important because even if you
have a residual connection, as our
theory was showing, that if we only have
positive eigenvalues, you can only do
attraction, so you're going to suffer
anyway when the homophily is is low. And
you can see, for example, here the green
plot. So, prod is a residual model, but
it's going to be terrible with low
homophily because it can only do
attraction.
Of course, if we have
uh models that can adaptively learn to
be either attractive or repulsive like
the sum or diagonally dominant, they
tend to be uh
performant
more robustly
with respect to the target homophily.
But, they are better essentially than
GCN, which is this uh violet one,
because GCN is not residual, and we know
by our by our theory that it will suffer
with low homophily, no matter the
spectrum of W.
And we have a similar ablation, but I
think this is actually even more
interesting, in my opinion, because
what we do here is effectively
explaining the smoothness of the
prediction thanks to our analysis,
because what we do is comparing the
homophily of our prediction. So, we're
essentially the smoothness of our
prediction versus the homophily that is
directly read from the encoding, so
without any evolution. And what we find
is again that if we only have negative
eigenvalues, so we can only do
repulsion, the smoothness is going to
decrease.
If we only have positive eigenvalues, so
attraction, the smoothness can only
increase.
Um neutral variants are of course more
robust.
But an interesting behavior is that the
encoding seems to learn to compensate
for when the dynamics can either do only
attraction or repulsion. So, for
example, if you can only do attraction,
then the encoding seems to learn to
separate things initially a bit because
it knows that inside the evolution, they
will then put uh, you know, put
get closer to each other.
Um so, conclusions.
We have a framework where the message
passing neural network's equations
minimize the multiparticle learnable
energy.
This allows us to analyze
uh the role of the channel mixing and
how its positive and negative
eigenvalues matter in generating a low
frequency dominant dynamics or a high
frequency dominant dynamics. This we
could refine some uh existing analysis
for MPNNs that uh specific uh statements
are in the paper. And from a practical
perspective, sort of the framework kind
of allows for educated choices because
we can have a more explainable
convolutional model where the spectrum
of the channel mixing is directly
related to the smoothness of the
prediction, and we kind of refuse sort
of like this idea that graph
convolutional models are too simple
because if we are residual, we have
enough negative eigenvalues in the
channel mixing, we can be dominated by
the high frequency.
Um and
some limitations and future direction,
what happens if of course we replace the
time mixing in W now with atomic mixing
that is symmetric but is also aware of
features in time.
But this would need to match this
efficiency requirement. What can we say
about dynamics that are neither LFD nor
HFD? Of course this exist and these are
maybe actually interesting. So, what can
we say about those?
Um and of course this energy formulation
in fact points to models that are a bit
more sophisticated but also more
inspired by physics and this is going to
be like I guess future work. Um
I thank you a lot for your attention. Uh
I hope that at least
the first half of the talk you could
bring something with you to to like
maybe look at GNNs or MPNNs with this
with the eyes of you know, this energy
and and
you know,
signal theory and yeah, I guess I can
take any other question now starting
from
Um you don't Yeah, you don't know if the
nodes have
homophily So, two points. First,
there may be heuristics to estimate that
based for example on the training set.
Um
but what I what I want to say is the the
framework does not need to know that
beforehand because
what we observe in these ablation
studies that W
will learn to have more negative eigen
values if uh basically this is needed
for the graph. So, you don't need to
inject this information beforehand. It's
this flexibility that will learn based
on the given graph. What we did is
explaining
the performance
depending on the given level of
homophily in this this in this synthetic
experiment and showing that basically
you can base you can literally explain
the drop in performance depending on the
homophily and depending on whether the
model was able to learn negative eigen
values or not.
Uh I have not reported a table here. Of
course, in our paper we we also run
experiments on uh real data sets for not
classification and we found that this
model despite being extremely simple as
I said, it's basically faster than GCN.
It will be very competitive with
way more sophisticated benchmarks that
have been specifically designed to take
to tackle heterophily.
Yeah, you're welcome. I hope that
answered your question.
Ah, you know what I'm looking.
Ah, yeah, sure.
So,
homophily means
that
the edge of a graph
connect
things that are similar to each other.
Um
So,
this very much applies for example to
social networks. So,
most likely
if you are um
on a social network and um
the the
people that you let's say uh
you follow
are going to be according into some to
some rule similar to you. Perhaps in
terms of age, perhaps in terms of
interest. So,
the edges of the social network will
tend to connect uh items or uh users for
example that are similar to each other.
Now,
if for example instead you are
you have a graph.
Uh so, this is homophily and this is
where because of this assumption
if you want to then classify on the
graph you would expect
a
sort of operations that denoise the
graph and uh smooth things out to
actually help because these operations
will increase the similarity between the
neighbors. The neighbors are actually,
you know, coming from the same uh latent
representation. They should have the
same label. So, this is good.
But, what happens in the other case? So,
for example, what happens you know if
you have a graph where um
for example um
on one side there are there are users
but then on the I want to separate users
from people that are cheating in a video
game.
And the edges are
uh if I report a given user that is that
is, you know, cheating in in in Warzone
and I'm not happy about it.
Now, the
in this case,
the edge is not connecting actually
items or in this case okay, players that
should be
placed together. So, if you now have a
process that
uh smooths things out, it makes
for example, myself increasingly similar
to the people I'm reporting, then this
would this would be bad. I mean, I'm not
classifying correctly. So, heterophily
means you actually want most of the
times to separate things that are
connected rather than place things that
connected uh together and give them the
same label.
And you can describe that
using low and high frequency because a
process that is low frequency dominant
place things that are um connected
together. A process that is high
frequency dominant will separate things.
And in in the framework I've described,
this could be like interpreted using the
this physics approaches where you have
attraction
and repulsion. So, are you going to
attract things along an edge, homophily,
or you this would work on homophily, or
you want to separate things along an
edge, this would work better on
heterophily.
Um so,
if
Okay, so that I'm I'm in the first
question um
I'm not sure if
there is a
specific thing you're asking about the
Laplacian. What I can say is
um
basically this method is as simple as it
gets or this is I mean I I call it a
method but the the reality is like it's
more of a framework and in fact I didn't
have time but in the paper we explore
how this framework could for example
support nonlinearities, activations,
attention mechanisms and so on. But
um
this specific model this specific like
instance of the framework I presented
you today is as simple as it gets
as in there is a a Laplacian symmetric
or a Laplacian
times the solution times the channel
mixing. And there are actually there is
active research to explain how you
to justify how you can do that in a very
scalable way. For example, you can
separate this was worked by
some of my colleagues as well. This is
sign where you can for example separate
the
um aggregation step from the learning
one. So you can sort sort of precompute
uh for once uh the Laplacian times the
solution and then you can learn
separately using MLP for example or
linear layers. And this
can scale to very very large graphs. So
the the
the scalability here is definitely not
an issue.
Uh this would uh answer
partly uh the question about
applications as in this can scale a lot.
But uh
the reality is I don't see the paper and
the work I presented as
an application-oriented type of paper.
It's more like
an understanding of
what blocks that are basically used
inside almost any MPNN which is the
channel mixing block
uh understanding a bit better its role,
understanding that if you want to have a
a grasp of what's happening inside your
MPNN. In fact, the spectrum of the
channel mixing
uh and how it interacts with the
spectrum of the Laplacian matters a lot.
And in fact, so much that the
distribution of its eigenvalues will
determine whether your MPNN will learn
to be
uh a smoothing MPNN or it will learn to
be a sharpening MPNN. So,
I don't I think the application of this
paper is more about perhaps you don't
need to to have a super complicated
models provided you that
the block you use, like the channel
mixing, which is a simple
everywhere present uh block, is
uh there is more inductive bias there.
There is more control. And this paper uh
explains that.
I don't have breakthrough uh yet.
So,
Yeah.
Hi, Francisco.
Hey.
Yeah, so I think there is no more
question.
Perfect.
I guess I can stop sharing.
Yes. So, if like we have question, maybe
you can
put it in
a Google Sheet and share with you.
Of course. Yes.
Um I uh
promise you that at least
the mathematical details are all um
uh in the paper.
Uh and uh but yeah,
let me know if you have any
There is There is one question.
Yeah, so
I think that the main the main take-home
message is
uh as I said of this paper is giving you
some techniques
that you can apply to understand some
MPNNs.
So, you have now a terminology
that is justified, that is this
low-frequency dominant, high-frequency
dominant, and I
I think it's actually quite interesting
now to investigate terminology that can
be more sophisticated as in what if it
you can't you are neither LFT nor HFT.
But then you can apply this type of
techniques to
you know, um
other
type of MPNNs. Um the heat equation is a
is an MPNN, but it's like there's
nothing learnable there.
Um but now
I think it's a it's an interesting
question to understand, for example,
how I can uh
uh investigate graph attention networks
or something that is nonlinear and has a
dependence in the solution via this
framework. That The answer is not always
this uh affirmative. Uh
the generally graph attention networks
are not gradient flows, they're not
minimizing energy because they are not
symmetric. They are row stochastic, but
they're not symmetric. Um generally,
almost always, never symmetric. So,
uh if you want to explain some more
explainability, so so to speak, in this
uh gradient flow framework, this will
give you constraints
in what you can do and what you can have
at the level of the equation. But
constraints at at most of times good
because it will allow you to have better
understanding, fewer parameters, and
and and if it if it give you also like
competitive performance then then that
this is all good, right?
At the end of the day, you know, if you
think at least about classical
mechanics,
you you always have all your Lagrangian
equations. So you always have some
functional that is some Lagrangian that
is governing your multi-particle
dynamics and this is
this describes
extremely complicated
physical systems. So the same sort of
intuition is here, right? So why
wouldn't we not
have an energy
perhaps increasingly more complicated
and this is sort of like more future
work that could
explain and and govern my my gene and
dynamics.
Um
So yeah, some of these techniques for
sure can be applied to many other
equations, but uh
the the take-home message is not all
differential equations are gradient
flows.
Uh
some symmetry has to be in the equation
for them to be gradient flows.
Uh
thanks. Now I'm embarrassed. But yeah,
thanks.
So,
there is no more question from the
audience.
So, so I think there's no more question.
Mhm. So,
for like for those who are interested in
working on this domain, they can maybe
mhm, contact you maybe by email or
LinkedIn. If you have some contact to
share to student.
Okay. Uh
Just put it in the Zoom chat.
In the Zoom chat? Yeah, I mean, I I
guess uh what's my
Yeah.
I guess you can reach out here and
Yes.
I should also have a Twitter handle, but
which I shared here, but I don't
remember. So, let me check. Oh, yeah,
this one.
Yeah, I'm not like a
I'm not too much like of a social media
person, I guess. Right.
Yes. Uh
Yeah, you you can you can reach out to
me on on the email. Also, um I want to
uh
I want to also have the
um
If you give me my 1 second, I just want
to type the right email, but my
I also have my main collaborator that uh
you can also uh
write to him that he's like also the
go-to person for any question, for
example, related to
coding. I
So, I think I might have LinkedIn, but
it it was an old master's student
account from like five or six years ago.
No, right now I
I basically I don't have LinkedIn, you
know.
I'm sorry about that.
Um
Okay, so um
it was it was really nice presenting
this. This is actually was the first
time presenting this, so I apologize,
but it must be like, okay, it's always
rough. It takes a lot of few few
iterations to to get it to get it good,
but yeah,
um
Can you share the link to it? Of course,
yeah.
Um
Yeah, sure.
I think I have it open here somewhere.
Uh
Yes, this one.
Um
Yes.
Okay.
Well, thank you so much.
Yeah, of course. Uh good luck and you
know, have a good continuation of the
school with the other talks. Uh yeah,
enjoy the rest of the day.